imagine an earth-like planet far larger
than our own nasa has actually
discovered numerous exoplanets dubbed
super earths which are over twice the
size of our tiny homeworld most of these
super earths can't support life but it's
interesting to imagine what sorts of
life forms we'd discover on a
super-sized version of a habitable world
photanum b is a speculative project
created by the brilliant steve mob
cannon who imagines just such a planet
and the incredible alien life that might
evolve on it and as usual i have links
where you can follow and support his
work down below so for this entry into
the archive we'll be voyaging to the
extraordinary alien world of photanum b
the planet gets its name from the greek
word of fatan which translates as to
arrive first a reference to the idea
that photanum b is the first planet with
alien life that humanity has arrived on
in this fictional narrative at almost
twice the size of earth with a higher
surface gravity and thicker atmosphere
conditions on fatanna b are quite
different from on our own planet and yet
the life here is downright awe-inspiring
reaching colossal sizes despite the
higher gravity but we'll come back to
that later in the video for now let's
discuss how humanity first reached these
alien shores i wish i could tell you
that in this timeline humans grew into a
grand interstellar civilization but the
truth is the author imagines humanity
drove themselves to extinction long
before our story begins their successors
are mysterious genetically modified
superhumans known as the deum who wish
to give their homo sapiens cousins a
second chance traveling to the newly
discovered photanum bee the powerful
deum placed a reborn colony of humans on
this habitable world and watched their
progress from afar but what the last of
humanity will find on this planet is an
ecosystem much much different from
earth's
beginning with flora plants like
everything on fatanna b reach gargantuan
sizes here on the southern
supercontinent a lush world of red
tinted vegetation flourishes the sheer
amount of consumable biomass in this
environment far exceeds that of any on
earth allowing the organisms that feed
on this flora to reach equally
staggering sizes
one of the first of these animals that
humans encounter are the giant
tianocodite relatively common herbivores
with iridescent green skin due to algae
that grows on their body and
symbiotically supplies them with extra
energy giant tianocodite also gain
energy by consuming plant matter in the
surrounding environment which they rip
from the ground with their flexible
arm-like jaws strange as this might seem
tyonokodite anatomy is a good average
example of a body plan on photonium b so
let's take a closer look at the inner
workings of these organisms beginning
our dissection the skeletal system of
tianocodite and many other massive life
forms we'll be exploring is made of
pyrite able to support far greater
weight than the hydroxyapatite bones of
earthly animals likewise their muscle
system is far more powerful than any
earth organisms with core muscles made
of more long-chained myosin fibers for
basic movements and a dedicated
secondary system of muscles for more
precise movement instead of a single
brain a decentralized neural system
sends commands to these muscles not
unlike the neural systems of some types
of starfish and coral finally you'll
notice that instead of eyes most life
forms on vetana b have ridges lined with
infrared receptors on their heads most
organisms also lack traditional mouths
instead having a mouth-like hole in
between two tentacle-like arm jaws that
bring food into the opening but keep in
mind taianokodites are just a baseline
and life on photonium b gets even more
interesting a distant relative of the
tayanokodites are the plane's dwelling
bronze cyanolopes life forms that use
their strange shuffle-like lower arm jaw
to dig for food these organisms move in
great herds of up to 30 individuals a
survival strategy similar to the hurting
instincts of many animals here on earth
at 10 feet or 3.2 meters in length
bronze cyanolopes could be considered
megafauna on our own planet but on
photon b they're actually on the small
side this has led to some human
explorers to attempt domesticating them
with mixed success
along the volcanic shores of photanim
b's coastal regions a hunter is
relentlessly pursuing its next meal this
is a black curva galvid a multi-limbed
predator whose arm jaws have hardened
into curved structures lined with pseudo
teeth used to ensnare its prey in this
regard the spiny jaws of the black
curvat galvade are analogous to the
mandibles of some earth insects these
endurance hunters might be deadly to
humans caught outside the walls of their
colony but they're actually just
mid-sized predators on this world which
compared to earth-mid-sized predators
puts into perspective how much bigger
and scarier life can grow on photon b
less common are great frigate peeds
rarely encountered life forms that
almost resemble extremely deadly living
trains their multi-limbed body structure
in some ways calls to mind the
appearance of earth insects like
centipedes or caterpillars curiously
great frigate peds hunt prey by ramming
into them at high speeds with their bony
front body protrusion acting as a
battering ram after a successful use of
this strange hunting technique the
creature's hooked jaw arms unfold from
hidden pouches and tear apart the prey
and if that's not intimidating enough
great frigate peeds are true goliaths
reaching almost 64 feet or 19.5 meters
in length although some of their distant
relatives can grow even larger
before we meet the relatives of the
frigate peds there's another fascinating
life form lurking in the snowy mountains
here far from the red plants of the
lowlands you can see the remains of its
latest kill meaning our culprit is close
by this is the bear trap hugger a
mountainous hunter that possesses a
shaggy coat of silvery fibers to protect
it from the cold not unlike the fur of a
polar bear on our own planet bear trap
hugger ancestry isn't fully understood
but the bizarre biting apparatus at the
front of its head is an effective knife
like tool when it comes to hunting prey
but far stranger hunters exist on photon
b
returning to the lowlands even the trees
on photon and b can be deadly although
the sethrakul corpse tree isn't a tree
in the traditional sense but a zeneco
zoophyte an organism that can gain
sustenance from both the sun and other
sources which in the corpse trees case
includes living prey blending into the
red vegetation these odd predators
strike down any animal that wanders too
close with the large claw at the end of
their arm the speared prey is then
inserted into a mouth-like hole near the
base of the arm pretty terrifying
another zenekozu fight is the blitz
spire a life form so bizarre and
unearthly it's hard to grasp at first
one of the single largest immobile
organisms on photon b the blitz spire
can reach a staggering 1
600 feet or
495 meters tall and grows indefinitely
throughout their life cycle until they
literally collapse under their own
weight and mass the tip of the blitz
spire has evolved incredibly to attract
lightning strikes the electrical
currents of which can then be released
to stun prey that gets too close to its
underground feeding tendrils these
living skyscrapers are truly a life form
unlike any other the largest mobile
predator in both modern and prehistoric
times however is the giant lactismid
which has reached a scale most
carnivores could only dream of the
larger relative of the frigate peds
giant lectismids can reach 102 feet or
31.1 meters in length the incredible
bulk of this creature is supported by
countless legs including larger
weight-bearing outer limbs and pairs of
thinner hooked internal limbs that can
aid in hunting prey giant lectismids
also have alarmingly well-developed
neural systems which makes them aware
enough to avoid most human settlements
although on rare occasions they've been
known to hunt humans for sport but even
for a giant lactismid not all life forms
are easy to take down take the
gargantuan castle walkers a group that
as the name implies are impenetrable
living fortresses and some of the
heaviest terrestrial grazers on photon
and b occupying a niche not entirely
unlike an elephant on our planet castle
walkers vacuum up plant matter with a
long jaw arm appendage covered in quills
to scare off any predators these
creatures are also quite intelligent
able to communicate with other members
of their species with morse code like
ground vibrations that they can perceive
through their feet as you can see by
this size comparison to other photon b
life forms plus a t-rex for good measure
castle walkers are true titans reaching
lengths of over 110 feet or 34 meters
but even castle walkers are small in
comparison to the final life form we'll
be visiting today the immense red wind
whales are among the most legendary and
awe-inspiring life-forms on photanum b
gliding through the open skies wind
whales are mainly made up of air-filled
cavities that allow them to stay aloft
despite reaching lengths of over 420
feet or 130 meters and possess wingspans
nearly twice that length aided by the
dense atmosphere wind whales function
like living paper planes possessing
retractable legs that work like
grappling hooks to anchor them to the
ground in turbulent weather when these
tethers fail however and a wind whale
passes away they create something called
a whale fall an event where organisms
from all across photanum b come to feast
on the fallen titan for the saga of
photanum b is a story of life and death
and now humans are a part of this story
at this point in the narrative's
development whether or not humans will
be able to survive long term in their
new environment is unknown bataan and b
is an ongoing project so who knows what
else might happen and what else might be
lurking on this alien world
thanks for watching please consider
supporting the author using the links
below and if you enjoyed this entry
please like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
you